shortly after stepping on board this
mobile clinic Francis Juarez became the
first person in Florida to participate
in an experimental treatment to fight
kovat 19
he's also the mayor of Miami who was
recovered from the virus and has been
symptom free for at least 14 days
researchers hope his plasma can help a
critically ill coronavirus patient
nearby I got three or four Instagram
messages that were very similar asking
if I would be willing to donate blood or
plasma and and and with the same number
I was actually at my parents house
because they were decontaminating my
house and I actually call back the
patient right away the patient's family
right away and they were very emotional
they were very very grateful and are
very hopeful that with this donation
hopefully he can he can be saved the
American national Red Cross wants other
recovered patients to do the same plasma
is the liquid portion of blood that's
full of antibodies that fight infections
blood is drawn and piped through a
special machine to extract the yellow
colored serum donors then get their red
cells and platelets back in a process
that takes a little longer than donating
blood recipients will then in theory be
able to share the donors active immunity
after first approving it for emergency
use the US Food and Drug Administration
has now authorized Johns Hopkins
University and the Mayo Clinic to begin
clinical trials to see if passive
antibody therapy may shorten the
duration of illness the severity of
disease or prevent people from dying
from it all together and to find a way
to boost the immune system of frontline
health workers and banded together to
try to work together for the common good
and I think in the end
science will went out the FDA gave New
York State's Department of Health
permission to conduct the experimental
procedure last month though it's only
been used on a handful of patients
Dianna Barrett's became the first
potential plasma donor in her state and
is working to connect recovered patients
to opportunities to save lives through
Facebook we are keeping a running list
of every study that we can find around
the country and making those available
and acting as a matchmaker of sorts
between research institutes and
survivors to make the system more
efficient and expedite the process
because we don't have time to waste
lives are on the line
this treatment predates vaccines and was
used to fight the 1918 flu pandemic as
well as more recent outbreaks of the
corona virus family like SARS and mares
one donation can generate nearly 4 units
of plasma and could help for people
however it's not known to be a safe and
effective treatment for Cova 19 we don't
understand a lot about the immune
response to this virus we're assuming
it's similar to other viruses and
they're good reasons to think that and
so we think that within seven to
fourteen days after the onset of an
infection that people will develop an
immune response and eventually make high
amounts of antibodies although exactly
when the peak of antibody production
will be we don't know and and how long
it will stay permanent we also don't
know that either institutions in 20
states are coordinating their research
through a national code 19 program to
answer those questions together they
hope to discover therapeutic treatments
that will help reduce the number of
infections and ease pressure on
hospitals and health care workers Andrew
Chappell
al Jazeera dr. hamid Meniere's a
virologist at Lancaster University in
the UK we appreciate your time very much
so Andrew did a very thorough job of
explaining this in the package but just
the bottom line what is it that this
particular type of therapy does I think
this is incredible discovery especially
when we don't have vaccine and
therapeutic and especially because we
already know that plasma treatment has
been used for many other infections such
as SARS MERS Ebola Spanish flu
and it's really a hundred-year-old
proven therapy so certainly this has
more advantage especially in the
frontline workers say dr. the nurses who
are highly exposed to the treatment
alert to the virus so using the puzzle
pigment plasma transfusions would
certainly give the force to the
frontline to minify to the to the
patient very effectively so what does it
do so the plasma itself contain a lot of
antibodies which are the molecules that
are required to neutralize the virus
it comes again for instance where and
someone in a healthy state is in fact it
with the virus body immune system that
comes aim and produce a lot of small
molecules we pour the monoclonal
antibodies those are antibodies which
are decisive factors for immunization so
if you take the plasma which is a spray
color yellow part of the blood from
those survivors this would have loads of
monoclonal antibodies and transfusion of
this plasma to any other vulnerable only
what a bunch of frontline workers will
provide them enough antibodies then if
they would become infected they will be
having enough immunity people we will
bind to these viruses and remove them
from the body are there any risks or
side effects to this you know a couple
of precautionary measures that need to
be K you can especially the time course
of infection so if you use the plasma in
the later stages of the infection that
the chances for the survival would be
relatively less so you have to apply the
plasma and at least stages of infection
ban the the proportion of the virus is
relatively less and that equate with the
level of antibodies in the plasma so
that is one thing the second issue could
probably arise if someone is already
having underlying causes are already
frail and have a very weak immune system
if you transfuse with the heavy quantity
of the plasma that won't cross me yet
but these are the things that definitely
need to be tested before it is approved
by the WH one FDA and that is what is
ongoing so if it is a proven oil if it
is approved what are the challenges of
scaling something like this up to be
able to do this on a big scale yeah so
just mentioned that one nation can
provide enough supply for four people so
I think the major challenges is really
into acquiring and scaling up enough of
the plasma that can meet the demand of
the people but the second challenge
media is that because the most of the
people who are in the community those
are probably not showing any clinical
signs so having enough diagnostic
capability so that you can screen people
who are infected before and have enough
antibodies in there
that can be used as a as a treatment and
the third challenge really would be is
to facilitate the volunteer chip that
people are willing to really donate it
and scaling up at the quantity that is
required to immunize that mass
population dr. Mohammad Munir we
appreciate your expertise very much